the Joe Rogan experience bipolar ape
because that is what we are we are men I
mean and and if you stop and you freeze
frame on somebody when they're having a
moment you can catch them in any it like
that whole spectrum the human spectrum
Center in st. and anything in between
yeah you can catch them in a terrible
moment or a great moment but you can't
decide that that's what they are all the
time and that's what we're doing now
let's say twenty two that we quantify
certain things that are just dumb like
there's certain things you just never
you're just not gonna bounce back from
the rachel dolezal thing what she
pretended she was black but realism
black too much I'm saying but there's
like those things where it becomes a
nationwide thing and I bet she's a
lovely lady I don't know I have no I
have no idea that might be empathy gone
wild or that might be sort of this this
I think a lot of times everybody wants
to be an individual they want that
that's always been a problem with the
human condition right you want to you
want to be you want to be unique right
yeah even though we all believe in
equality we all want to be not equal we
want to be a little better than the next
guy or at least unique yeah and that's
maybe where competition comes from and
stuff but I think sometimes people
negotiate that issue in that problem
with with a very clumsy apparatus with a
really weird way of doing it I'm gonna
be transracial or I'm gonna I'm gonna
wear dishes in my ears and and and
literally cover my whole face with
tattoos that's fine super common there
might yeah there might be a better way
to negotiate that that problem you're
having because it's a it's still pretty
surface you ever look at the hash tag
face tattoo on Instagram no holy [ __ ]
there's a lot of people getting their
face tattooed yeah like it's like what
slow down yeah slow down it goes back to
wanting to be seen well I think what
you're saying makes a lot of sense in
terms of like people wanting to belong
to a group that seems cool and like
black people seem like overall a cool
group right like you have good music
behind it they have a funny way of
talking they have all these amazing pro
athletes they have a totally different
kind of culture and you identify with
that culture but you can't get in
because you're a white girl you like
[ __ ] it's also to do it's all thing I
think also there's a romance too you're
on the outside looking in its struggle
oh yeah
and being having been oppressed and all
those things and yet you yet you triumph
yet you find a way to be funny yet you
find a way to be colorful yet you find a
way to be artistic
I mean rap came from from from the South
Bronx wallet was literally on fire
yeah and rap is just one aspect of it
Ryan I mean think about some of the very
best end of comedians some of the very
best musicians do yeah and you think of
the percentage of the population that's
black 12 the percentage that become
elite professional athletes I mean what
is the percentage of NBA players that
are black it's it's something crazy a
lot of it's also just what is it you
think I don't know but it's pretty high
I mean they're 69 personally probably
why I said that number
Jamie it might be just also that there
are two there are two avenues open to
you in a lot of black communities at
least it's changing but you know it was
sports and music yeah for sure
that's that probably plays a part in it
no doubt about it
but it's also there's a sort
extraordinary number of professional
athletes like elite athletes yeah that
just happened to be black yeah and what
is that though is it genetic is it is it
the environment they're coming from I
mean it's it's a fascinating thing to be
explored because for all this talk of
racism if you just want to be really
honest there's a lot of
african-americans and have some pretty
phenomenal genetic traits like fit like
Carl like think of like who's like Jamie
who's like the biggest freak all-time
athlete basketball player would it be
probably the Bron James Ron James
probably right yeah and then you have
like Michael Jordan's another free
athlete right now I mean how many of
those sparkly white guys like that are
you like Larry Bird but Larry was a
phenomenal shooter but he wasn't the
kind of freak athlete LeBron is dr.
Jordan would used to literally fly
through the air yeah there are a couple
guys that can do things like that but
they don't have the overalls yeah well
so so if you look at there's a book
called the sports gene that talks about
this yeah
if you look at Africa it's it's it's
probably the most genetically is the
most genetically diverse part of the
world right I mean the Africans from the
Biafra Coast are totally different the
Africans from from say the highlands of
Kenya Ethiopia the Africans from the
Sudan the Dinkas a newa tend to be
almost seven six sometimes certainly
seven feet is not that uncommon and many
people don't realize Egypt's a part of
Africa very much so I mean the Tunisia
Morocco that's more Arabic right then
you've got I mean it's fascinating this
is what really was fasten let's go to
Ethiopia Ethiopia they grow to an
average height beautiful people there's
a lot of trade in that side of the world
Eritrea there they've been renowned for
their beauty if you just step over the
border just just go right to just one
one south or one north you are going
into Sudan or the South Sudan tall's
people in the world toss people in the
world 90 some of them can be like a fist
off at eight feet that's work like Manu
Bowl and those people came from okay if
you go just another country just one
more country east now you're in the
Congo and that's home to the pygmy so
you got the shortest people in the world
in one country and then just cross the
board any of the tallest in the world in
that country so Africa is insanely
diverse but if you look at the athletes
with the most explosive power and if you
like that that includes the fast people
in world who are in Jamaica and who are
you know in the United States
genetically you can trace them back to a
very primarily you can trace them back
very small part of Africa according to
this book the sports gene which is the
Biafra coast and so that is where that's
where you'll see the fastest most
explosive people however having said
that you can hear too young
Sanders talking watching this white
running back 215 pounds he ran a 4-3 540
and he was like I can't say this on TV
but he can run run he can run run and it
was true it's like you you haven't seen
a white guy run a four three five in
forever yeah it's pretty rare there's
gotta be some Viking genes floating
around sure but there's there's no I
don't think there's any black
cornerbacks in the NFL can you show us
it's just fascinating when you stop and
think about just the sheer
number of people involved in
professional athletics the sheer number
of people that make a living playing a
game with their body yeah but I don't
know if that kind of athleticism helps
you become a champion in tennis you know
they're different depends on the sport
it's sports specific right
[Applause]